Hello everyone and welcome to a really interesting game that took place in the chest 24 banter blitz match between Magnus Carlsen and
Grandmaster Peppa cuenca. Now, this is round two in round one pepper cuenca defeated his opponent georgian grandmaster Levon Pencelaia
with a score of 9 to 0 so magnus definitely took this match seriously, and this is a game
well, obviously from the match it's uh
it's the first game of the match and it's the one where Magnus said that he's just gonna try a quick attack showing little to
no respect as the position allowed it
So without further do, let's check it out Magnus opens with d4 now
We have Knight to f6 and Bishop to g5. He goes for the trompowsky and he mentions briefly that he didn't check what
Cuenca plays, so that's why he's gonna go for a slow line.
d5 and night to d2. Most common is just captures on f6. So Knight to d2
We have e6, e3 and now Bishop to e7.
Just making room for castling with c3 and now of Cuenca castles
Bishop to d3 by Magnus and b6 now preparing the bishop to b7 and the knight to e4
We have f4 by Magnus grabbing more control of the e5 square. Bishop to b7 and now
Magnus mentions in the video that he decides the capture on f6, he doesn't want allowed the knight
to lend on e4. So just Bishop captures, captures and the knight g to f3
We have c5 by black and now h4 and already Magnus mentions that maybe some Bishop to h7 action is possible here
What he means by this is if black plays something like knight to e7 he can sacrifice the bishop on h7
and if king captures, knight g5 will be very strong. The Queen can come to h5, and it's a well known
bishop sacrifice where if you go back with the King then just Queen h5, and black will have very, you know,
big difficulties defending this position.
If you capture just h captures you open up the H file for the rook.
So you'd have to play something like this
but then you allow queen captures on f7
and then after the King moves the knight comes to f3 and is just a very strong position
For white, which would of course be winning in the end.
So here even if you allowed it
you would have to go for something like captures, captures, knight g5 check, king h6
and, even though, this is good for black
in a three-minute blitz game, it's it should not be playable. Especially not against
Against a strong man, a grandmaster, and especially not against the world chess champion, where King is stuck on h6
and you will waste a lot of time trying to defend this.
So after h4, Cuenca goes for h6, he just defends it
We have g4, preparing g5, and Bishop to e7
So if g5 comes you can advance the pawn to h5, you don't have to worry about your piece being under attack
We have g5 by Magnus and, now, h5.
Of course, you don't want to open up lines in front of your king and now
Knight to e5 and the g6 are both excellent, excellent, moves Magnus decides to go for g6
and now f captures and g6. If you try f5 to
try to keep the position close just Knight e5 and then it's
it's a pretty straightforward victory for white.
So after g6, we have f captures on g6, bishop captures on g6 and the now Knight to d7
We have knight to g5.
Again black doesn't achieve anything by trading here
you just open up the H file for your rook and then it's just over.
So here Knight to f6 adds another defender to the position
you will be controlling the h7 square, which is really important,
and also you're not just allowing the Queen to infiltrate with Queen captures on h5
and here Cuenca allows Knight captures on e6
but Magnus isn't interested in winning material since if something like this then,
yes, he wins the exchange but he developed all of black's pieces and he doesn't want to do that, he prefers to keep the initiative.
so Bishop captures on h5, and now comes Queen to d6 developing and now the other rook can also
come into the game plus he wants to exchange lights bishops with this maneuver
So Bishop to g6 now Magnus makes  room for the h pawn to start marching forward.
We have bishop to c6 with the plan of Bishop to e8
and, now, h5
we have Bishop to e8 and now Queen to b1
a nice move that allows White to continue the advancement of the H pawn because now the bishop is protected
You're just gonna push here, captures, open up the h file and continue in that fashion
Capturing doesn't do anything as the Queen very easily
takes the bishops place and then just h6. So we see captures on b4
and now, while h6 is possible immediately,
you don't want to waste too much time calculating.
You know in a three minute blitz game
So C captures on d4 and rook to c8 and here
it's best for whites to just capture on e8 but Magnus decides to push h6 right away and this allows
Pepe Cuenca a very interesting,
well, exchange sacrifice that allows him to stay in the game
So here he plays rook the c1 with check, it removes the defender of the bishop on g6
So you have to capture it Queen captures and now Bishop captures on g6. That's why it was better just to capture and then push
H6 as you would not have this, um, maneuver
So we have bishop captures in g6, h captures on g7, king captures and now knight D comes to f3
Magnus also briefly mentions that Queen to c7
also playable where black would have to trade Queens and then you just grab another pawn with check
And then you pick up the Queen
You're up the exchange so you can just go into an endgame but he goes for this line instead : knight D to f3.
Queen b4 with check, we have King to f2 and now Knight to g4 with check.
King g3, the king is very safe there,
and now Knight to h6 coming to f5 with check
But here at Magnus just plays Knight captures on e6,
and it was in this position that Pepe Cuenca resign the game
as there is nothing more he can do here.
1. The rook is under attack.
2. If the King moves you you can pick up the night.
3. You can come to c7 with the Queen
Uh, so it's just
It's just an unplayable position for black
So this is the first game of the match Magnus won it and in the end after nine games
The result was 8 1/2 to 1/2 for Magnus.
So one game was drawn. The other eight games were won by Magnus and
yes, I don't know if you've heard but Magnus Carlsen is currently, I don't know if he still is,
but today he posted that he's
The number one player in the world in fantasy league football
whatever that is, I don't know.
I haven't played it but sounds sounds like well, if you're first in anything in the world, that's worth mentioning.
So just thought I'd put the put it in there as well.
And also if you are interested in checking out the other games from this match
I will put a link in the description below with a link
To the chess 24 website where you can check it all out
and also if you want to check out the exact video of Magnus Carlsen stream
I will also put that in the description so you can also check that out
so, yeah, that's the game. A very nice attack and it really was a
Quick attack where a little to no respect was shown so there we have it.
I do hope you enjoyed it, I would like to thank Rohan Polidano
met back with Skatinsel, SiK GmbH and Rohan Bhansali for  contribution to my channel.
Thank you a lot - really appreciate it as usual
You can check two of my previous videos here
Thank you for watching and I will see you soon, continuing with the coverage of the, well, Frieda Graham,
pre checking up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess world such as this look of this match here
And do be a part of the subscribers video 2020. It's going to be awesome.
So thank you all I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your day